d'urgence est maintenant
ouverte.
- La commission Rouleau
a replongé l'assistance au coeur
(klaxons)
Deenenregistrements des
klaxons ont été présentés.
Les témoins ont décritomomomomol
perturbé, rues bloquées, odeurdt
dans leur quartier.
Cette résidente malvoyantennnni
à la rescousse.
"Peux-tu ver r me chercher et
me sortir d'ici?"
"Le simple fa d de porter un
masque dans la rue, faisait de
vous une cible d'intimidation".
des centaines de courriels
de résidents terrorisés...
... qui avaient l'impression
d'avoir étles autorités en l'abe
policiers dans leur quartier.
Les communications des élus
avec le service de police
étai
du convoi a-t-elle été prise
au sérieux?
NATHALIE CARRIER, dg, zone
amélioration commerciale, Vanier
- Pourqules rues? Puis on a eu s
différentes réponses.
- Cette la communauté d'affairee
souvient d'un appel inquiétant
avec l'ancien chef de la police
d'Ottawa, Peter Sloly.
- Freedom!
- Des anecdotes ont de quoi
surprendre. Comme un magasin
grande surface, qui rapportait
avoir écoulé tout son invee e eà
ours lors de la troisième fin
de semaine de manifestation.
Alors, Louis, la ville d'Ottawa
et ses policiers semblent avoir
Ils auront à répondre aux
nombreuses questnsns soulevées
lors de ces premiers
témoignages.
- Pourquoi la police d'Ottawa
a-t-elle lé é entrer
les camions dans la ville?
L'ampleur de la contestation
les policiers semblaient
dépaésés, peu présents dans
certains quartiers résidentiels,
selon, ce qu'on a entendu d d de
responsables policiers,
lala semaine prochaine, sera
central parce qu'il nous
permettra peut-être de
les autorités semblent avoir
été prises de court.
cette période initiale a été
déterminan p pour la suite de
la crise dans la capitale,
et constitue un pas dans la
par le gouvernement fédéral
de lnvnvocation de la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence. Il y a
une conseillère municipale,u'u'e
était d'accord avec l'invocatior
le gouvernement fédéral
parce qu'elle était désespéréeat
libérée. Mais je vous rappelle
que de manière plus large,
le gouvernement t t t t t t t ta
expliquer en quoi il était
confronté à une crise nationale,
pas seulement locale.
- Merci beaucoup Louis,
- Je vous en prie.
- Au revoi